我郭哲隆说话算话
我买10050说到做到
你们看到我现在没带手表了
台股周三一度跌破四万点
分析师郭哲隆就在直播透露
砸一亿买0050
但为什么不直接买正二
郭哲隆则表示
不推荐杠杆型ETF的核心原因
就是不能为了追求高报酬
而把投资人推向极高风险
就连财经达人清流军也发文
点出0050最近一个月大跌10%
關心各位還扛得住嗎
不過台股傳奇交易員聚人傑就發問提醒
當前大盤已面臨流動性問題
而被處置的個股更是陷入嚴重缺氧
這絕非只影響開槓桿的投資人
不過如果民眾資金有限之下
又想逢低不止
該怎麼辦呢
我們並不建議只要設定跌幾%就買
而是採用分批買進的方式
這樣的成功率通常會比一次性的重壓來的更高而臺股是否報融資斷頭潮證交所極喊話截至七月二十七號全市場信用交易整戶擔保維持率約百分之一百七十五
遠高於百分之一百三的法定追腳門檻
全市場融資擔保維持率
也還是高於原始維持率百分之一百六十六
市場風險整體可控
短線震盪的狀況可能持續進行
所以比起一次性的重壓
比較建議
就是第一個不要第一天就all in
投資資訊平臺卻公告即日起停止提供融資維持率
證券維持率及整體維持率
相關歷史資料也將陸續下架
強調後續以證交所公告為主
另外國際股市中韓股盤中反彈
但隨後又收斂
目前韓國限制個股槓桿ETF
投資上限擬設20%
保證金7月31號起升到3000萬韓元
遏止過度槓桿交易穩定市場
国民也关注台湾政府后续动作
TV新闻 送不了